hey everybody welcome into Market takes
I am your host Dion Robert Bowen thank
you for being with us right here on
YouTube we are discussing diving and
breaking down opening up doing all
things on the CPI Consumer Price Index
uh the inflation report that just
dropped this morning markets have
already reacted have been reacting we've
got the market just opening up right now
we're going to talk to you all about
that and all about why we are seeing
this exuberance from the market I don't
want to say whether it's rational or
irrational but certainly some exuberance
from the market right now Futures
showing the NASDAQ just jumping off the
boards out the gym all that so we're
going to break down what we saw in this
report and why we're seeing that
reaction so like I said we're going to
talk all things the report of course I'm
going to give you the numbers the
headline numbers the core numbers some
of those numbers within the report that
really move the market and why they
mattered we're also going to talk about
how this report compared to expectations
as well as what some of the most
important pieces are and maybe some of
the most important pieces that aren't
really catching those headlines are
drawing those headlines right now
whether you're watching on Twitter or
reading on some of your favorite
websites of course like wsj.com we're
going to get into the market reaction
across markets talking not just stocks
but bonds crypto Commodities FX all that
stuff and most importantly we're going
to be talking about what this means and
what this means moving forward so not
just for today as we're looking out
towards that December Federal Reserve
meeting and as we look out into 2023
really what you can expect from this
move and what this means big picture so
let's dive all the way into it right now
uh the October CPI report that just came
out today showed inflation Rising 7.7
year over year that is well below
expectations expectations were for 7.9
percent economists predicting that we
finally get below that eight percent
number this was the lowest inflation
reading year over year wise that we've
had since January so the second lowest
reading of the year and as you remember
inflation was just kind of spiking up in
fact we're going to throw a chart up
here on the screen to kind of illustrate
what we have seen from inflation so as
you look at that chart right there you
see inflation picking up picking up
picking up and then we have that 9.1
percent number that's when markets
really freaked out and ever since then
you've seen this consistent slowdown
right you saw 9.1 then 8.5 and 8.3 8.2
now we are down below eight percent
again as you look there the reading we
got for October which was last month was
the lowest we had seen
since January since the very beginning
of the year when that pickup theme
really started so just wanted to put
that on the screen to illustrate what we
have seen kind of long term coming into
this report and why that Trend down has
markets so excited that's what it's all
about it's all about the trend one
report a theme does not make one
reporting Market does not set but what
we are seeing is a consistent trend of
inflation cooling down and moving back
towards the Federal reserve's target of
two percent
um look core CPI that's another number
that had really been watched that was at
6.3 percent or 0.3 percent on the month
uh both the headline numbers in terms of
month over month and year over year were
below expectations that core number came
in below expectations core matters
because it's what the FED focus on
focuses on
and it strips out things like food and
energy which can move around a lot which
have been big pieces of this overall
inflation story so when you strip those
out the overall inflation story is
improving things are getting better
inflation is coming down but also on
that core number housing being the
biggest piece of that you're seeing a
cooldown we'll talk a little bit more
about that in just a moment so this was
lower than expected expectations were
for 7.9 percent uh last month as I said
that was what economists were predicting
that would have been the lowest level
since January this one even lower than
that 7.7 percent
um and the 0.4 month over month number
that was also lower than expected and
you also had a revision of September's
number revised down to point four
percent from 0.6 so again consistently
declining numbers on that CPI report
that's what matters we're seeing a
consistent Trend down for inflation that
means that the fed maybe can chill out a
little bit that there's less resistance
that consumers are maybe going to be
hurt a little bit less all those things
are good for markets good for stocks and
that's why we're seeing this kind of
outsized response uh in the stock market
especially as remember we've seen we had
seen that core number month over month
pickup it was expected to rise to 0.6
percent which would have been the third
consecutive increase in the core number
instead we saw a cooler a lower core
number and the number for September be
revised lower those are all good things
um we remember the core CPI number last
month was the highest since 1979 so
getting back down from that seeing a
consistent cool down of inflation is
definitely a good thing for investors
and that's important because CPI core
sets inflation expectations and
expectations are very important for
driving the actual pace of inflation now
the one yeah but and this is one thing I
want to highlight here because you're
not going to hear a lot of yeah but from
your favorite people on TV yeah but I
want to read you something from the
report real quick here the index for
shelter contributed over half of the
monthly all items increase with the
indexes for gasoline and food also
increasing so we're still seeing
increases for housing we're still seeing
increases for food and we saw a pickup
in gasoline again after a consistent
decline for most of the past three
months that has been holding down the
index that's definitely something to
watch for if we get again a pickup in
those gas prices that could start to you
know undo some of this Goodwill that
we've seen from the market so let's talk
about some of the most important numbers
in this report what move the index was
uh and I'll quote you again from the CPI
report itself indexes which decline were
used cars and trucks Medical Care
apparel and Airline PR and airline fares
excuse me those all were negative they
all declined so you saw a month over
month decrease in all of those used cars
and trucks Medical Care apparel Airline
us you also saw utilities you know
that's what we're paying every month
that was down 4.6 month over month that
was the biggest decline in overall the
index so again these are bills that
you've got to pay every month that
declining utilities that certainly had a
large impact on the overall index and
this slowdown that may be temporary
we're seeing expectations for colder
weather through the winter and as we
move into those colder months if we see
that materialize those utility costs
could start to rise back up so again
that's something to definitely keep your
eye on watch those natural gas prices
those fuel prices those things that
contribute to what we're paying each
month on our utility bills because the
big decrease there is a big part of why
we saw this index move lower the overall
CPI index food Rose 0.6 percent moving
further away from that one percent month
over month increase that we have seen
really going back to June you had seen
food prices rising kind of steadily at
one percent a little bit over or a
little bit under and then you get that
point eight percent reading a month ago
now down to point six percent so again
food prices not that they're not that
they're declining we're not seeing
decreased food prices but we are seeing
a slower pace of increase uh that's big
and you also saw a 19.8 almost a 20
increase in fuel oil watch out for that
watch out for those gas prices because
that could be picking back up and again
that doesn't just contribute to one
piece of the index the index is is
measuring it one way but fuel
contributes to everything because gas
prices are on delivery it's almost
everything that comes to you gets
delivered to the stores to your house to
wherever it goes buy something that uses
Fuel and if those fuel prices start to
pick back up consistently we could see
this progress that we've seen reverse so
watch out for fuel prices as you're
looking out at the future of this index
the other piece I want to talk about is
housing inflation in the last few months
we've seen housing inflation driving up
the overall Index this month we saw
housing inflation kind of cool down but
one thing I want to point out to you is
this existing home sales index or
existing homes index that just came out
about a week ago from the National
Association of Realtors that showed
existing home sales Falling by 24 in
this in September down for the eighth
month in a row however Prices rose by
8.4 percent now why does that matter why
are we talking about one report I just
set up one report you know isn't going
to make a thing well if we're seeing
home prices decline for eight straight
months if we're seeing a 24 decline year
over year in home sales why are prices
rising I it speaks to the sticky demand
for home prices or the sticky demand for
homes the fact that people are still
going out buying and they're still
paying higher prices even though now
they're paying a seven percent handle on
their mortgage rates right they're
paying seven percent six and a half have
sometimes seven and a half depending on
your credit
well they're still paying more and
higher home prices that's going to drive
the overall cost of homes up the overall
cost of housing up because folks who buy
houses a lot of them then rent them out
to other people and when you pay a
higher price when you buy well you got
to drive the rent up so that's something
to watch even though we did see a
Slowdown in housing costs overall in the
CPI again that existing home price
higher we've just got a big generation
of Millennials who need a place to live
housing was underbuilt for about a
decade there's just not enough places
out there so even though folks don't
want to they're still going out and
paying higher prices for a lot of these
homes much of that going on at the upper
end of the spectrum on on the existing
homes but definitely something to watch
out for so let's get into markets
because that's I think the big piece of
this story how the markets reacted and
we saw a big outside exuberant rally in
stocks we're looking at the NASDAQ up
right now 4.6 percent whoa that's a big
number uh you're saying the Dow the s p
both up the the Dow is only up 2.2
percent so the rally we're seeing the
NASDAQ those high flying risky Tech
shares a lot of worry about the the
future for some of those that has really
lagged the Dow for some time in October
we saw the NASDAQ uh rise about four
percent while the Dow Rose almost 14
percent had its largest monthly gain
since 1976. the NASDAQ only leaked out a
four percent gain well we are starting
to see that reverse and the NASDAQ is up
more than double what the Dow is up
right now because folks love risk at
this moment when we're seeing inflation
kind of turn down and slow down at least
uh you you saw it was a rough day
yesterday as this FTX and finance story
was hitting crypto which was hitting
other retail and to some extent other
institutional investors folks really
selling out of kind of a lot of
different things well they are buying
back in right now as we see those big
numbers uh the NASDAQ up big around four
and a half percent S P 500 up about
three percent uh it's just really if you
were watching those Futures prices it's
just kind of whoop and then we jumped up
after the release of that CPI report
really across the board risk assets are
going up uh and and those safe havens
folks are moving out of those if if
we're looking right now at crypto this
was one of my my favorite things looking
out of the market right after that CPI
report came out Bitcoin jumped 10
percent it's about 9.75 right now
ethereum up 16 uh Litecoin is up 20
and again like when we're talking about
the rally when we talk about irrational
exuberance well
this asset class was doomed because of
or some people thought this asset class
is doing I should say don't let me don't
let me editorialize it all some people
thought this asset class was doomed
because a fundamental story FTX a huge
player in the Bitcoin Market was
essentially insolvent you had Sequoia
affirm that invested hundreds of
millions of dollars into FTX write the
value of that company down to zero that
shows you that the Bitcoin Market that
cryptocurrency in general is at risk
right now there's a real risk of this
Market collapsing and crashing on itself
and yet after a hot CPI print after one
report that shows that I'm sorry a cold
CPI printed a CPI print that shows
inflation cooling down you're seeing a
10 rally in Bitcoin 15 16 rally in
ethereum 20 rally in Litecoin I think
I'm just telling you right now that what
you're seeing is a little maybe maybe a
little rational exuberance as the man
Allen Greenspan once said
if you're looking at those bond yields
that was another thing that I caught big
moves today in the bond market
particularly now these are these are
supposed to be the calm folks the folks
who are driving the bus being
level-headed huge moves the 10-year note
is down 20 25 basis points in yield that
means that is a huge move usually it
takes months to get a 25 basis point
move in the 10-year note we had that
today in one day 23 basis points down on
the yield of The Seven Year note all
those back below four percent uh you're
seeing the three year note down 26 basis
points the two-year note which is most
sensitive to expectations for what the
Federal Reserve is going to do is down
31 basis points today that is a huge
move the two-year note yield down at
about 4.34 so
big moves from the bond market big
expectations for the FED to do less and
to sort of slow its role and I think
that's something that bears watching
let's talk about that just a little bit
talk about what this report means for
the Federal Reserve because we've got to
watch the fed that's the big thing
moving the market I think folks might be
getting a little too excited and not
listening to the chairman as they did in
June when we got this rally as they did
a little bit earlier in in September
when we got the other rally I don't
think folks are really hearing the
chairman Fed chair Jerome Powell has
said clearly unequivocally he wants
tighter Financial conditions he wants
bond yields higher because that makes it
more expensive to borrow it also gives
you an impetus to save rather than spend
look do I want to put money in a a
two-year treasury or a one-year treasury
or a CD or a savings account that's
going to pay me three or four percent or
do I want to go out and spend seven
eight percent borrowing money for a
mortgage well I'm a rational consumer I
want to say save that money I want to
put that away these are the highest
yields I've seen in a long time as that
goes away that loosens Financial
conditions and makes it harder for
inflation to come down and that's what
the FED is focused on so I don't think
folks are here in the chairman right now
he's saying we want tighter Financial
conditions he's saying we we want stock
prices we don't want stock prices to
click higher we don't want a big rally
in the stock market we certainly don't
want a big rally in the treasury market
and that's what we're seeing today and
the reaction that we've got from markets
really could have the opposite effect of
what Traders think because the FED
chairman has said very clearly and Nick
temeros my colleague here at the Wall
Street Journal who talks to those folks
who listens very intently and said the
committee wants tighter Financial
conditions they want those bond yields
higher those stock prices lower and when
we have the kind of exuberance we're
seeing that may cause the FED to react
more strongly than they otherwise would
listen to the FED don't fight the FED
listen to what the chairman has to say I
don't offer Financial advice but I will
tell you when the Fed chair Jerome
Powell talks you need to listen
all right so listen that's going to
really wrap it up here for us on Market
takes I want to talk about what we've
got coming up out of the gate for the
rest of this week some other reports to
watch because CPI is by no means the
end-all be-all tomorrow we get the
University of Michigan consumer
sentiment index Central Bankers will be
looking for signs that inflation is
becoming entrenched or not inflation
expectations what are folks thinking
about for the next year the next three
years but those five to ten year
inflation expectations if those start to
rise too far above the FED where the FED
wants them to be they want them anchored
around two percent you could see some
more hawkish talk some more talk about
more rate hikes more talk about keeping
rates high and really crushing the
market so watch out for that tomorrow
the University of Michigan consumer
sentiment index that's out as well as on
Tuesday we get PPI the producer price
index that's what that's what businesses
are paying for the products they've seen
and we know businesses are passing those
costs on to Consumers and then some they
are raising their prices by more than
the increase in prices that they're
seeing so watch out for that report on
Tuesday and then next Wednesday I think
the biggest report that we are going to
see between now
and the end of next week is that
Wednesday retail sales report we will be
right here doing it live for you on
Market takes breaking down what we saw
from the retail sales report the market
action all that look is spending rolling
over that's the big question and
normally we want no we want the answer
to be no we want to say that folks are
still going out spending money still you
know dropping cash and buying those name
brand products right now you probably
want spending to be rolling over if
you're an investor because that means
that inflation is going to slow and that
means the FED can kind of take their
foot off the break that they have been
stepping on so aggressively for the past
couple months uh that's definitely worth
watching and we'll be here at Market
takes watching that listen I know you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me on Market takes
thank you so much that's going to do it
for us I am Dion Robert Bowen reporter
at the Wall Street Journal join us on
Wednesday for Market takes we'll see you
then we'll catch you there hopefully
next time